les forces armées russes n'ont jamais
participé et ne participe pas aux
conflits armés sur le sol ukrainien a
affirmé le porte-parole du président
russe dmitri peskov
1 expliquant l'augmentation de la
présence militaire russe à la frontière
avec l'ukraine
lors de son entretien quotidien avec les
journalistes
pour lui le fait que la russie effectué
le transfert de ses forces armées à
l'intérieur de son propre territoire
notre voie enquêtait personnes comme
cela ne pose aucune menace à personne je
vous propose d'écouter certains scénario
pareil provoquerait une nouvelle
escalade des tensions près des
frontières de la russie d'un évidemment
cela exigera des mesures supplémentaires
de la part de la russie pour assurer sa
sécurité
la fédération de russie ne menacez n'a
jamais menacé personne c'est sur cette
base que repose notre position
malheureusement la situation réelle sur
la ligne de contact est effectivement
très effrayante
il y à des provocations de la part des
forces armées ukrainiennes
il ne s'agit pas de cas isolés ils sont
multiples quant à la rhétorique
je viens de répondre à une question
concernant les déclarations de kiev sur
la nécessité d'engager les forces armées
de l'otan
j'estime que les déclarations de ce type
parle d'elle-même le vice ministre russe
des affaires étrangères andreï rudakov à
son tour qualifié les spéculations quant
au conflit imminent entre la russie et
l'ukraine d'une fac nous écouter je suis
convaincu que toutes les spéculations
concernant une sorte de conflit imminent
entre l'ukraine et la russie est un
nouvel exemple de fake diffusé en
premier lieu par les autorités
ukrainiennes
la russie est intéressée par aucun
conflit avec l'ukraine
surtout militaire nous ne savons en
aucune manière les efforts de l'eau à
eux
la russie a voté pour la prolongation du
mandat de la mission spéciale
d'observation qui vient d'être
renouvelée avant-hier et espère que l'ol
se continuera de contribuer au règlement
de la situation en ukraine et à
l'atténuation des tensions dans le
donbass notamment dans le cadre des
activités de la mission spéciale
d'observation je rappelle qu'il s'agit
de la montée des tensions entre moscou
et kiev
à la suite des exercices militaires
russes menés en crimée